et vous feriez erreur Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénateur si vous
considériez que le texte que le
gouvernement vous présente affaiblit le
Sénat car vous le savez et vous le savez
parfaitement ce texte sera adopté en
dernière lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale avec les principes et les
équilibres qui vous ont été donné et
c'est pour ça que vous devez accompagner
ce texte quel que soit le vote qui sera
le vôtre ce texte sera adopté il
renforce le Sénat trè illusion le cumul
des mandats les jeux sont faits avant
même la discussion au Sénat le message
délivré par le ministre de l'Intérieur
dans son discours d'introduction est
limpide peu importe ce que le Sénat
adoptera amendera ou votera s plié la
bataille est perdue d'avance
la limitation du cumul des mandats
éternelle serpent de mer François
Hollande en fait une promesse de
campagne symbole d'une rénovation
politique le candidat hollandefsi sur
une mesure populaire l'opinion publique
est majoritairement favorable au non
cumule c'est pour je fer voter dès le
début du prochain
quen la fin du cumul d'un mandat parl
avec unection d'exécu loc cette promesse
de campagne porte la patte de Martine
auri alors première secrétaire du Parti
socialiste la mre de lîle présente le
non cumu des mandats comme le gage d'une
démocratie plus
moderne déjà en mai 2010 et malgré
l'hostilité d'une majorité des sénateurs
socialistes elle vient plaider sa cause
disis des mots
prophétiques position du nom cumule est
pour moi un élément majeur de la
rénovation et de l'image que donne notre
parti et que je suis convaincu que au
sénatorial comme au présidentiel c'est
un parti ouvert capable de se renouveler
faisant rentrer des jeunes des femmes
des hommes et des femmes de la diversité
qui aura encore plus de crédibilité
auprès des
Français bon à bientôt bien merci bon
c'était bien ah c'était
super à bientôt au revoir au revoir mais
3 ans après
le malaise est toujours présent malgré
l'insistance du gouvernement la Haute
Assemblée à la veille de l'examen du
projet de loi n'est toujours pas rentré
dans le rang et SICI le président du
groupe socialiste François repsamen pose
au côté du Premier ministre il incarne
pourtant l'opposition du Sénat au texte
du Gouvernement l'ami du président est
devenu frondeuri ma conviction pour
l'intérêt de la qualité de la lo
législateur c'est qu'il est important
que les sénateurs puissent conserver un
mandat exécutif local au Palais du
Luxembourg le front anticumule
transcende l'éclivage politique il se
compose d'une partie des sénateur
socialiste de l'UMP du groupe centriste
et du
RDSE le RDSE le Rassemblement
démocratique social et européen
principalement des radicaux de gauche
est un allié indispensable de la
majorité
socialiste mais sur ce texte la
résistance est totale cette loi sur le
non cumule en fait c'est c'est un cacheX
de d'une opération qui va mutiler une
partie de notre démocratie territoriale
notre démocratie représentative en
général on voit bien que dans face à eux
communistes écologistes et une partie
des socialistes il souhait avec cette
réforme donner une autre image du Sénat
plus
moderne si euh euh des élus des
sénatrices et des sénateurs de la
majorité parlementaire euh ne souhaite
pas ce texte donc il sera retoqué on va
renvoyer justement euh aux citoyennes et
aux citoyens le fait qu'on s'occupe de
nos petites affaires entre nous et qu'on
leur demande pas leur avis et que ce
texte sera sans doute retoqué mais
Infiné il sera adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui tend aussi à montrer
que aujourd'hui les Sénat les sénateur
en tout cas le Sénat sa
parole compte pas en juillet c'est Simon
Sutour qui est nommé rapporteur du texte
un rapporteur qu'on envoie au
caspique voilà je pense que N nous
agissons pour pour une bonne cause que
c'est un bon projet de loi doncess de
convaincre mes collègues qu'il
fautadopter mais il peut compter sur le
soutien sans failleés de la commission
des lois Jeanpierre
suur
positif
excusez-moi les deux sénateurs chevalier
blanc du nom
cumule et en juillet 2013 voilà le
gouvernement rassuré l'Assemblée
nationale chambre plus docile adopte le
projet de loi à la majorité absolue
conséquence même avec un vote négatif du
Sénat loi organique devrait être
entériné le texte adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale et qui arrive au Sénat
interdit le cumul entre un mandat
parlementaire et un mandat exécutif
local un sénateur ou un député ne pourra
plus être maire ni président de conseil
général ou
régional à condition de laisser passer
les prochains rendez-vous électoraux
rapporteur MAM et monieur les sénateurs
vous le savez la date d'application du
principe de non cumule a fait
débat je me suis impliqué
personnellement c'était mon rôle lors
des travaux préparatoires pour une
application en 2017 après le
renouvellement général de chacune des
deux assemblées cette
solution permet à chacune et à chacun de
s'organiser de prévoir de garder sa
liberté de choix si les électeurs
évidemment le veulent bien parce que en
définitive ce sont eux qui
décidentette après de lois précédentes
en 1985 et 2000 c'est donc une nouvelle
étape pour le non cumule des mandats
mais il sera toutefois toujours possible
pour un sénateur ou un député de rester
élu local la réforme en cours euh
n'empêcherait pas si elle était adoptée
euh un député ou un sénateur de
conserver un mandat local les députés
comme les sénateurs pourront rester
conseiller municipal conseiller
départemental conseiller régional et il
ne me semble pas qu'il faille
nécessairement détenir un mandat
exécutif local pour être un élu
local la loi fait l'impasse sur la
limitation des cumules dans le temps de
même pas un mot sur le cumul dit
horizontale un même élu pourra donc
encore cumuler la mairie la communauté
d'agglomération les communautés urbaines
l'intercommunalité et bientôt les
métropoles des oublis condamnés par de
nombreux
sénateurs bi je pense qu'il est
totalement anormal et que d'ailleurs il
y a un conflit d'intérêt important entre
un élu qui est maire d'une grande ville
par exemple et qui va diriger la
métropole ou la communauté urbaine ça me
paraît absolument impensable donc ça
existe les cas sont nombreux et
notamment à gauche y compris à gauche
voilà donc ça ça aurait dû être dans le
texte on sait très bien bien que en plus
quand on est maire et président de
communauté d'aglo on préside en plus
toute une série d'organismes qui font
que il y a un vrai cumul horizontal qui
s'est développé en particulier avec la
décentralisation et que on ne peut pas
traiter du cumul vertical sans traiter
du cumul
horizontal cumuler une pratique très
française dans nos assemblées les élus
aux multiples casquettes sont légion à
l'Assemblée nationale 82% des députés
exercent un autre mandat et ils sont 45
% àumulés avec un mandat exécutif local
dans la Haute Assemblée la situation est
quasi identique 77 % des sénateurs
détiennent au moins un autre mandat et
48 % d'entre eux ont un mandat
exécutifjour salutcques monsieur
président et au Sénat les poids lourds
du cumul sont nombreux sénateur maire de
Lyon de Marseille de Dijon et de
Strasbourg pour ne citer que les plus
connus
une exception française en Europe
héritage d'un état
jacobinist c'est l'héritage d'une France
extrêmement centralisé c'est-à-dire que
c'est l'héritage d'une époque où l'on
considérait que pour porter les dossiers
locaux et bien il fallait euh que le
maire de la commune soit également
parlementaire à Paris de façon à avoir
l'oreille du ministre ou de
l'administration centrale et c'est vrai
que dans un système extrêmement
centralisé comme celui que connaissait
la France le cumul des mandats avait sa
justification sauf que cette
justification elle s'est largement
émoussée avec les premières lois de
décentralisation mais Jean-Claude Gaudin
exemple à l'appui estime qu'il est
toujours nécessaire de cumuler dans
l'intérêt des territoires face au
rapporteur du texte il se souvient d'une
époque où il n'était plus que maire de
Marseille et j'ai donc vécu cette
période d'une manière pas très agréable
voilà alors il m'est arrivé pour les
dossiers qui est marseillais de demander
rendez-vous à un ministre bon le
ministre accorderé le rendez-vous mais
changé trois fois la date puis on était
reçu très courtoisement très
convenablement d'une manière
républicaine
dit-on j'ai pas senti qu'il y avait des
résultats positifs après tandis que
lorsque vous êtes au Parlement de la
République que vous soyez députés ou que
vous soyez sénateur pour nous c'est le
Sénat d'abord on est présent au Sénat on
côtoie les ministres toi d'abord les
collaborateurs des ministres ça fait
avancer les choses autrement vous les
connaissez même pas vous pouvez
questionner un ministre devant la Haute
Assemblée et si vous le questionnez en
plus un peu
brutalement en présence du Premier
ministre et bien j'avais observé que les
dossiers marchaient beaucoup plus
vite le sénateur maire de Marseille
donne le bâton pour se faire battre par
les anticumules qui estim que dans nos
assemblées siègeent trop de barons
lo allez bonsoir car quels intérêts sont
censés représenter les sénateurs ceux de
leur seul territoire ou ce de la nation
très vite le débat se cristallise autour
de la place et du rôle du Sénat il faut
bien comprendre que ce n'est pas juste
la question du statut de la situation
personnelle des députés des sénateurs
qui sont concernés en fait cette loi est
de nature à changer profondément le
fonctionnement du Parlement mais aussi
le fonctionnement de nos institutions et
nous disons nous les sénateurs udi UC
que on ne peut pas changer une toute
petite partie de nos institutions si on
ne fait pas une réflexion globale sur
toutes nos institutions les partisans du
cumul des mandats s'appuient sur
l'article 24 de la Constitution dans
lequel il est inscrit que le Sénat
assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
République
une spécificité défendue bec et ongle
par les
sénateurs on ne peut pas faire du
parlementaire un élu hors sol c'est
idiot le
Sénat doit représenter les collectivités
locales comment peut-on imaginer qu'il
puisse le faire si on on coupe le cordon
bilical merci beaucoup
alors nous devons défendre le Sénat
parce que si le Sénat devient la même
chose que l'Assemblée nationale un jour
se
posera le fait de dire mais on peut
supprimer le Sénat et on peut avoir
qu'une seule chambre dans ce pays or le
Sénat est un équilibre par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat et le
représentant des collectivités
territoriales pourquoi empêcher un maire
de vouloir être sénateur c'est pas
possible mais attention à trop mettre en
avant la représentation des territoires
la compétence législative général du
Sénat pourrait être remise en cause on
peut entendre l'argument qui consiste à
dire et bien voilà le Sénat représente
les territoire il est donc une chambre
des territoires et comme tel doivent y
siéger les représentants de ces
territoires très bien mais alors il faut
tirer la conséquence de ce que l'on
avance quant à la composition du Sénat
et quand on rôle qu'on veut lui voir
attribuer si le Sénat est une chambre
des territoires sur le modèle du
bundusrat allemand alors ses
prérogatives et bien légitimement
devrait être réduite et quanton est
uniquement aux questions intéressant les
collectivités locales françaises le
bicamérisme tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
serait donc caduc le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale pourrait ne plus
détenir les mêmes compétences mais c'est
un risque que sont prêt à prendre une
majorité de
sénateurs le matin du 18 septembre juste
avant la discussion dans l'hémicycle la
commission des lois rejette le texte du
Gouvernement mais surprise elle adopte
trois amendements autorisant les
sénateurs à conserver une fonction
exécutive
locale il y a sans doute une majorité au
Sénat pour adopter une solution euh
positive qui partte de l'idée au fond
que exercer ensemble un mandat de maire
et un mandat de parlementaire ça permet
de bonifier dans l'intérêt des citoyens
l'exercice des deux fonctions si le
Gouvernement et l'Assemblée nationale
s'accroche à une vision plus
dogmatique nous pensons que le Sénat qui
représente les collectivités
territoriales de la République c'est ça
sa légitimité doit à tout le moins faire
en sorte que les sénateurs puissent être
maires ils sont des maires parmi les
maires des élus locaux parmi les élus
locaux c'est le cadeau empoisonné de
l'UMP des centristes et des radicaux de
gauche au
gouvernement même nos deux chevaliers
blancs du non cumu affichent leur
fatalisme mon prognostic c'est que le
Sénat n'adoptera pas majoritairement le
texte pour ses raisons ce n'est pas un
scou tout le monde le sait voilà mais
c'est assez logique par rapport à la
position de la majorité de notre
commission sous les ors de la salle des
conférence avant l'entrée dans
l'hémicycle les discussions sont
courtoises les clivage gauche- droite
bien
loin mon ami socialiste moi je le
suisort et ben nous on est des
républicains si c'est voté c'est voté
vous n'êtes pas du même bord mais vous
êtes d'accord tous les deux pas
forcément chacun a son forcément je
pense que c'est c'est quand même assez
démagogique cette loi sur le non cumule
et sur le mandat unique et en même temps
je pense qu'il est utile de mettre des
limites sur le cumul aussi parce qu'il y
a des cumules dont on voit bien qui sont
pas raisonnables VO je pense qu'on est
d'accord làdessus d'ailleurs al était un
des premiers à démissionner de son
mandat de maire en prévision justement
de de ce qui allait se passer donc on
peut être raisonnable mais en même temps
faut pas être démagogique le mandat
unique absolu ça me paraît tout à fait
démagogique avec l'arrivée du ministre
de l'Intérieur et du président de la
commission des lois il y a tout de suite
salle des conférences de l'électricité
dans l'air oucoute j'ai pris l'eau parce
que je vouis pas te
manqué
présidentou mais je me suis mouillé je
suis un sénateur qui se mouille je suis
pour le non cumul des mandats de façon à
ce que
chacun fasse une tâche tu sais il y a
beaucoup de talent dans tu sais pourquoi
parce que tu inaugures trop de choses
inaugurer un peu beaucoup de talent dans
la République tu vas voir j'ai un seul
mandat et bien tu en as eu plusieurs
j'en ai eu avant mais là ça fait 10 ans
12 ans que j'en ai qu'un la semaine
dernière pendant le weekend j'ai été
visité 12 communes tu fais ça ça empêche
pas d'être présent sur le TER mais quand
même tu as pas donné l'exemple au début
de ta carrière parce que j'ai regardé n
deand responsabilité que et au début tu
vois j'ai été trois fois débuté j'étais
que
débuté l'Assemblée
nationale a forcément le dernier
mot bien sûr il faut savoir uniquement
si le Sénat participe de ce
mouvement le débat d'aujourd'hui ne va
pas servir à grand-chose parce que y
compris contre une majorité des
sénateurs le gouvernement a décidé
j'allais dire de céder à une for populme
qui ferait croire au travers du mot
cumular qu'il y aurait une espèce d'abus
à exercer un mandat local exécutif et la
fonction de parlementaire mais on se
battra jusqu'au bout et c'est le sens de
ma
présence l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi organique
interdisant le cumul des fonctions
exécutive local avec le mandat de député
ou de
sénateur
jaces mard le tribin du cumule des
mandats plus qu'un bouleversement c'est
une révolution ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est vous monsieur le ministre à la
page 52 du rapport je vous cite je ne
sous-estime pas l'ampleur de ce
changement qui est une véritable
révolution et bien une révolution on ne
doit pas la faire à la sauvette par une
procédure accélérée en session
extraordinaire haché par les congés
d'été comme des braconniers
législatifs
qui font leur coup nuitamant le visage
masqué par la cagoule de la
modernisation de la vie
publique monsieur le ministre pas vous
pas ça au nom de tous ceux qui nous
rassemble au nom de notre histoire et
encore davantage de l'avenir de cette
république que nous voulons forte
rassembleuse respectueuse je vous
demande de rejeter ce texte tel qu'il
nous l'est proposé et d'adresser à
exécutif le message de la liberté de la
Haute Assemblée au service de la
République vive le Sénat de la
République vive la
république le ton est donné le débat est
lancé et la roste ne tarde pas pour
d'autres le nom cumule est indispensable
à la modernisation de la vie publique et
au renouvellement de la classe politique
il y a aussi me semble-t-il dans ce
débat une forme de démagogie
parlementaire qui consiste à flatter les
habitudes et à refuser le changement et
le mouvement si nous voulons faire en
sorte que notre assemblée ce Sénat se
renforce puisse jouer pleinement son
rôle alors il ne doit pas rester à
l'écart des mouvements plus généraux qui
sont réclamés par nos concitoyens si
nous voulons que la politique soit de
nouveau respectée c'est-à-dire que notre
démocratie fonctionne alors il faut pas
à pas avancer sur le chemin qui nous est
proposé il faudra même monsieur le
ministre aller un peu plus loin c'est ce
à quoi je vous invite c'est ce à quoi
j'invite ce gouvernement et cette
majorité oui le changement est
pour le coup dans ce domaine le
changement et je m'en réjouis c'est
maintenant les institutions aujourd'hui
ne correspondent plus à ce qu'est la
société française aujourd'hui
voilà moi je trouve qu'elle il y a une
la dimension
démocratique a été gommée et et et et
moi je je trouve regrettable que les
élus se sentent détenteurs de pouvoir
mais pouvoir qu'il ne détiennent que
grâce aux citoyennes aux citoyens aux
électrices et aux
électeurs car quels que soi leurs
arguments le message des procumules
passe mal dans les médias et auprès de
l'opinion publique l'image de la Haute
Assemblée est
écornée les sénateurs vont donc mettre
en avant le non cumul des
indemnitéset amendement pour objet
interdire tout simplement aux
parlementaires de cumuler leur indemnité
parlementaire avec toute autre indemnité
découlant d'une fonction élective et je
pense que il devrait y avoir un large
consensus sur cette proposition ça
montre la sincérité la détermination des
élus qui veulent cumuler encore une
fonction locale et une fonction
parlementaire véritablement on sait bien
que ce n'est pas pour les indemnités
qu'ils font ça c'est un vrai choix choix
de
vie inflexible les sénateurs vont
persister sur la voie de l'exception
sénatoriale ces amendements prévoient de
créer un régime d'incompatibilité
spécifique au sénateurs et donc
différent de celui applicable aux
députés ce qui serait inédit depuis
1958 je ne comprends pas cette idée de
cette différenciation vous êtes des
parlementaires vous êtes des
législateurs et votre seul argument
porte sur le fait que le sénateur
devrait avoir un autre mandat qui serait
un mandat local exécutif et ça ne tient
pas debout et ça n'est pas cohérent par
rapport à la Constitution et par rapport
à la cohérence de celle-ci je crois que
c'est indispensable d'adopter au minimum
cet amendement si on veut justifier
l'existence du Sénat à côté de
l'Assemblée nationale je suis sûr que
nous sommes très nombreux très
majoritaires dans cette assemblée pour
penser que ça
serait simplement conforme au rôle
spécifique qui est donné au Sénat que de
permettre un sénateur d'exercer en même
temps un mandat un seul mais un mandat
exécutif
local tard dans la nuit l'exception
sénatoriale voté par une large majorité
de sénateurs de droite et de gauche
parmi lesquels 25 socialistes une
alliance mal vécu par certains membres
de la majorité ça n'est pas une surprise
moi personnellement j'ai voté contre ces
amendements mais ça n'est pas une
surprise le ministre lui-même l'a
indiqué il savait
que l'ajout de l'UMP de l'UDI des RDSE
et de quelques socialistes ferait un
vote qui qui met un terme en fait au
sens de de la loi tel qu'il l'a voulu
voilà donc ça préjuge un rejet enfin une
adoption ici mais qui sera qui sera le
contraire de ce que voulait le ministre
nous allons considérer que c'est c'est
une soirée gâchée qui ne qui n'aidera
pas à montrer un scénat moderne dommage
dommage vraiment mais pour d'autres bien
au contraire c'est une soirée réussie
une leçon donnée à un gouvernement
puisqu'on nous dit que ça sert à rien
qu'on dise ou blanc ou noir puisque
l'assemblée décidera donc comme on n pas
l'habitude de faire
potiche ben on s'est un petit peu pas
amusé mais manifesté et révolté donc ça
c'est une jolie victoire de la
révolte le 19 septembre la loi est
adoptée par par 208 voix pour et 107
contre une stratégie habile les
sénateurs votent la loi sur le non
cumule8 le Sénat a adopté le projet de
loi organique interdisant le cumul de
fction mais en s'exonérant du dispositif
un tour de passepe dénoncé par le
rapporteur du texte peut-être que je
suis naïf mais non franchement je
pensais mes collègues dans le majorité
plus en phase avec la réalité depuis le
début et donc la lutte c'est quand même
pas tout à fait habituel que on vote
contre le gouvernement qu'on représente
mais en même temps ça montre bien la
liberté qui existait qui existait ici
don Tacte mais ça n'est pas de de nature
à entraîner je ne sais quelle
déflagration au final l'Assemblée
nationale devrait remagner le texte et
supprimer l'exception
sénatoriale sénateur et députés logés à
la même enseigne celle du non cumul une
réforme qui ne peut être qu'un point de
départ évidemment que la réforme du
cumul des mandats ne va pas suffire à
elle seu à rénover la vie publique notre
système qui est profondément
déséquilibré qui est marqué aujourd'hui
par une très grande primauté du
président de la République ne va pas
d'emblé se rééquilibrer du seul fait de
la réforme du
cumul donc si on veut appliquer le nom
cumule pour les parlementaires alors il
faut donner au Parlement qui est un des
plus faibles d'Europe des prérogatives
nouvelles et parlementaires des moyens
supplémentaires renforcer les pouvoirs
des parlementaires mais aussi repenser
le statut de l'ensemble des élus par
exemple revaloriser les indemnités des
maires des petites communes ou favoriser
leur retour à la vie
professionnelle après la loi sur le non
cumu la route est encore longue pour
changer le statut et les pratiques des
élus de la
République bien merci
c'était bien ah c'était
super monsieur le présid monsieur le
Président par toujours un plaisir de te
voir mais je me suis mouillé je suis un
sénateur qui se mouille je suis pour le
non cumul des mandats